[Musica]
oggi è il 26 ottobre
agli inizi della settimana prossima ci
sarà la luna nuova
non so se voi avete mai fatto caso
quando c'è la luna nuova si vede una
piccola falce luminosa ma noi riusciamo
a vedere la piccola fascia luminosa ma
non vediamo la parte oscura non la
vediamo perché rimane nell'ombra rimane
invisibile ma essa non è che non esiste
semplicemente che noi concentriamo
l'attenzione sulla parte visibile mentre
il resto rimane celato rimane nell'ombra
così sono i conflitti i conflitti
mostrano come la falce della luna nuova
soltanto una parte che è legata a quella
che può essere chiamata le posizioni le
richieste i voglio le recriminazioni
delle persone e nasconde tutta una parte
che non si vede ma che esiste che è
fatta invece di interessi che sono i
veri motivi per cui le persone fanno
quelle richieste che sono i bisogni le
stanze silenziose che sono mosse sotto
le nostre azioni mai fatta anche dei
nostri desideri delle nostre paure delle
nostre preoccupazioni delle nostre
aspettative
ci sono due episodi nella mia vita che
hanno cambiato completamente la mia
visione del conflitto
il primo risale esattamente a vent'anni
fa era il 1999 e mi trovavo in sicilia a
salina sulla scogliera di pollara che
peraltro è famosa anche perché hanno
girato il film il postino con il
fantastico massimo troisi a pollara si
va non soltanto per le bellissime
spiagge ma anche per assistere a uno
degli spettacoli che è considerato tra i
più belli al
i tremonti che possono essere visti
appunto dalla scogliera di pollara
ecco quella sera ci sarebbe stata la
luna piena
io non avevo idea di che cosa avrei
visto a un certo punto davanti nel mio
stesso asse visivo io vidi il sole
tramontare e la luna sorgere di di gli
opposti insieme il sole la luna nascono
est e tramonta nuove ma noi non
riusciamo a vederli insieme e quindi
pensiamo che siano opposti che siano
contrapposti ma è soltanto la nostra
ristretta percezione che ci porta a
vederli in quel modo è soltanto una
questione di come guardiamo e da dove
guardiamo il secondo episodio risale
all'anno successivo e il 2000 e maggio
del 2000 e sono a milano presso
l'università degli studi dove assisto a
una conferenza dove conosco i membri
della commissione di verità e
riconciliazione che era stata voluta da
nelson mandela per risolvere 30 anni di
conflitto di apparta ed attraverso la
via negoziale che cosa fecero i
sudafricani che cosa fece nelson mandela
innanzitutto si pose una domanda e si
chiese come facciamo a far convivere
sullo stesso territorio
le persone che hanno commesso i reati e
le persone che li hanno subiti le
vittime dei reati o i parenti delle
vittime stesse
forse per me che all'epoca facevo
l'avvocato penalista c'era un'unica
risposta facciamo un processo
cerchiamo i colpevoli e li condanniamo
ma durante sudafrica
i reati che vennero commessi furono
veramente atroci avevano dei mezzi dove
violarono tutti i diritti umani
addirittura quando si trovavano un corpo
scomodo qualcuno magari che era stato
picchiato durante un interrogatorio e
quindi dovevano sbarazzarsi del corpo lo
prendevano lo mettevano su una graticola
accendevano il fuoco e dopo 16 18 ore e
di quel corpo c'erano solo le pelli
io avvocato penalista all'epoca dicevo
beh no prova no condanna non puoi
condannare un reo se non ci sono le
prove se non c'è il corpo è invece i
sudafricani scelsero una via
assolutamente innovativa la chiamarono
commissione di verità e riconciliazione
chiedero la possibilità a coloro che
avevano commesso i reati di recarsi
davanti a un pubblico come questo anzi
molto più grande dove magari nel
pubblico c'erano madri che alzavano la
mano e chiedevano dove poter trovare un
osso del loro figlio da seppellire ma
magari quell'osso non ci sarebbe mai
stato il processo non avrebbe mai potuto
dare una risposta a quelle madre invece
loro usarono uno strumento importante
usarono lo strumento del dialogo usarono
lo strumento della verità certo che per
me avvocato penalista mai e poi mai
avrei potuto dire al mio cliente
adesso vai e racconti la verità per
altro noi non lavoriamo con la verità in
senso assoluto ma lavoriamo con la
verità processuale che quella che si
forma nel fascicolo processuale che
quella nel penale che deve intervenire
per andare al di là di ogni ragionevole
dubbio invece loro lavorarono con un
concetto molto importante per me fu
illuminante lavorarono con il concetto
della verità dialogica ovvero quella che
è ricostruita sui vissuti sui percepiti
delle persone
quello che importa è ciò che le persone
hanno percepito e vissuto non tanto una
ricostruzione di come le cose sono
effettivamente andate
certo la soluzione dal punto di vista
appunto del sudafrica fu concedere
l'amnistia a coloro che raccontavano la
verità e loro lavorarono appunto su
quello che è il dialogo la verità
dialogica si forma sul dialogo sulla
possibilità che le persone possano
ricostruire un dialogo perduto
quell'attenzione non viene più messa sul
soggetto autore del reato come soggetto
passivo destinatario di una sanzione ma
come soggetto attivo che è chiamato a
ricostruire è chiamato a fare qualcosa
che possa porre rimedio
alla sua condotta criminosa quello che
viene chiamato giustizia riparativa
ovvero una giustizia appunto che non è
tesa soltanto a comminare una pena a
colui che ha commesso reato ma è tesa
soprattutto a riparare i danni e tesa
soprattutto a rispondere a quella
domanda che ogni vittima si pone perché
proprio io perché è proprio me e quindi
loro lavorarono con questo strumento
fondamentale è uno strumento di cui noi
abbiamo bisogno e che costituisce anche
quello che è il nucleo di quella che
oggi viene chiamata la mediazione
ora voi capite che questi due episodi
hanno cambiato completamente la mia
visione della vita e soprattutto mi
hanno permesso di considerare e di
rendermi conto che tutti noi siamo
immersi all'interno di un paradigma io
lo chiamo paradigma di partenza è un
paradigma basato sulla contrapposizione
è un paradigma dove le persone sono
intrappolate all'interno di un circolo
vizioso dove ognuna ha delle precise
convinzioni dice sono io che ho ragione
sei tu che hai torto sono io nel giusto
sei tu hai in errore e quindi senza
rendersene conto loro alimentano un
meccanismo che le in trappola il
conflitto è fondamentalmente una
trappola
il conflitto è fondamentalmente un
assenza di conoscenza di cosa succede e
che cosa si nasconde come vi dicevo
prima
dietro quel lato oscuro della luna
peraltro se ci pensate bene anche gli
avvocati sono totalmente intrappolati
all'interno del meccanismo della
contrapposizione anzi per noi l'altro è
chiamato controparte
io sono necessariamente chiamata a
contrappormi all'altro non posso fare
diversamente anche perché se non lo
faccio il giudice potrebbe non assumere
le prove a discarico delle eventuali
ragioni del mio cliente per cui questo
meccanismo è molto forte e molto
radicato ed è molto vecchio comunque
indipendentemente dal fatto che io sia o
non ha
avvocato tutti noi siamo immersi dentro
questo meccanismo e non ci rendiamo
conto che questo meccanismo nasconde
degli automatismi ovvero nel momento in
cui io ti attacco to automaticamente
pensi che la cosa giusta e corretta sia
contrattaccare
c'è un detto che ho appreso qui in
questa bellissima città che e napoli che
dice se sei ferro watt
se sei incudine state allora questo
detto nasconde esattamente due modalità
che sono due automatismi che dicono se
sei ferro watt
ovvero se ti trovi in una situazione di
potere di supremazia
bhatti colpisci attacca se invece sei in
una situazione in cui sei incudine devi
subire devi cedere ma vi assicuro che
nessuno di questi due meccanismi
funziona anzi tutta la gestione
costruttiva di un conflitto si basa
sull'imparare a scoprire le alternative
a questo codice binario vedete tutto
dipende dalla descrizione del mondo che
ci è stata data
se io ho ricevuto una descrizione del
mondo dove mi hanno detto che questo
modo ostile che chi pecora si fa lupo se
la mangia che nella vita bisogna
combattere che bisogna spingere per
ottenere allora io rimarrò incastrata
dentro il meccanismo della
contrapposizione qualcuno che mi ha
descritto il mondo in questo modo mi fa
riportare addirittura pensateci bene
provate a pensare se avete ricevuto una
descrizione del mondo di questo tipo e
magari da bambini siete finiti dentro un
litigio e vostro padre vi ha sgridato
dicendo che voi non eravate stati capaci
di farvi valere
allora che cosa succede che io da adulto
quando incontro qualcuno magari che mi
offende lo attaccherò ferocemente oppure
viceversa se ho ricevuto la descrizione
del mondo in base alla quale mi hanno
detto che questo è un mondo dove tendere
alla pacificazione
che i bravi i bambini non litigano in
quel litigio corso da bambino quando
sono tornato a casa da mio padre mio
padre mi ha detto no
i bravi i bambini non litigano quindi è
meglio cedere è meglio lasciar perdere e
quindi io che ho ricevuto questa
descrizione che cosa mi è capitato che
si magari ho rinunciato o ceduto ho
lasciato andare ma però mi sono anche
frustrato e quella frustrazione ha
generato poi della rabbia magari del
risentimento che ho scatenato
successivamente nei confronti del mio
complice ente magari usando le parole
sbagliate nel momento sbagliato a volte
anche nei confronti della persona
sbagliata
tutto questo perché nessuno mi ha
insegnato a capire una cosa molto
importante che il conflitto non è
soltanto legato a una descrizione del
mondo basata sulla sopravvivenza
certo il conflitto una lotta e leone si
mangia un altro animale quell'animale se
ne mangia un altro però questo è tutto
inserito all'interno di un ecosistema
mentre noi esseri umani abbiamo
dimenticato l'ecosistema e siamo finiti
in quello che io definirei un equo
sistema dove rispetto quelle descrizioni
del mondo che abbiamo ricevuto
non siamo in grado di effettuare
movimenti differenti ma vorrei usare
un'altra immagine
vorrei dirvi che il conflitto è come una
danza
se io ti invito a danzare la danza del
conflitto tu aderisci se io sono
aggressivo tu sei simmetrico e quindi
sarai a tua volta aggressivo nei miei
confronti oppure se io sono aggressivo
to scappi esce di a seconda della
descrizione del mondo che hai ricevuto e
in questa danza senza accorgercene
sapete che cosa succede che noi ci
pestiamo reciprocamente i piedi
io non ti osservo non ti ascolto non
guardo come danzi e quindi ritengo di
essere nel giusto
sono io che compie passi di danza giusti
sei tu che stai sbagliando sei tu che
non sai danzare e questo crea quella che
si chiama la ricorsività del conflitto
siamo ancora imprigionati all'interno
del meccanismo della contrapposizione ma
noi possiamo cambiare la danza possiamo
imparare a danzare diversamente per
farlo dobbiamo mettere in luce delle
competenze dobbiamo imparare ad
osservare
dobbiamo imparare ad ascoltare dobbiamo
imparare a sentire l'altro se io ti
osservo capisco che passi di danza
stai facendo se ti ascolto capisco quali
sono le tue esigenze quali sono i tuoi
bisogni
se ti sento posso danzare insieme a te
in maniera differente allora se io
voglio entrare nel nuovo paradigma se
voglio imparare a uscire fuori dal
meccanismo della contrapposizione devo
imparare a cambiare il punto di vista
allora se salgo su quella scogliera di
pollara
se vedo riesco a vedere le cose in
maniera diversa
allora mi rendo conto che il meccanismo
del conflitto era soltanto una
contrapposizione legata come vi ho detto
ad automatismi ea meccanicismi ma se
cambio la mia il mio modo di vedere le
cose le cose che vedo cambiano e allora
mi accorgo che non ho paura del
conflitto non ho paura né di essere un
incudine né di essere un martello perché
l'accordo nasce da tre note io tu noi
benvenuti in un mondo possibile grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]